oh there's a cop
camera down
damn it
here's how i turned 130 to the potential
1900 on one day of garage sale but more
importantly how you can too
[Music]
come on
[Music]
i mean right off the bat the [ __ ]
trash truck is [ __ ] me up these three
minutes might cost me the whole thing
go right here
open this one
[Music]
trash talk episode seven i think drock
is back did not oversleep every minute
counts in the trash talk battle so the
more you can dominate this little
traffic scenario
or gary you know better
me
that's you sold you
whoa
yeah
you sound ecstatic
wait a minute i hear drock it's saturday
morning
i'm pretty sure i know what you're doing
we're trash talking
you know what i'm going to a town wide
that i've never done yeah west milford
i don't even know where that is
more jersey suburb life for 97 of you
are gonna be like how do i find garage
sales we've established this go to the
cut google pound wide garage sale google
is your [ __ ] mother here's a link
that goes into detail on all my garage
sale stuff why is there traffic on
[ __ ] saturday morning
no there's not enough people hungry
enough to go garage sale they're not
hungry enough
[Music]
keep on pouring every time
[Music]
[Music]
we both saw a lot
which is this leveling
three baths
oh how about that lego thing this one i
was going to do for 10. this is me take
a look at it would you do 10 for these
two
yeah i'll do that all right thank you so
much have a great day bye guys
we struck quick
look at that all day long
45 50 bucks on some real [ __ ] those two
things is like what some people spend
six hours at retail making minimum wage
on this is real out here they talking
like they don't know a king when they
see one see him in person he take it
back like a refund balling with my
brothers on my playing d1 daily checking
chicken he gon spin it watching reruns
say they real but they clones of me i'm
my cousin in the pen with more phones
than me i got daily correspondence i
gotta learn christmas
they tagging me like they knew me they
actually living goofy i'm tagging
flicking flex in the muscle like
penitentiary 1968 not always
how much is this
there was a mix of two things there
yeah so the houses are 20 bucks apiece
it's 40 bucks for 10 bucks there see i
mean i'm not going to take it but 10
bucks is 40 bucks easy
thank you have a great day
hunch buggy you know what a punch bug is
i can't believe you got me i'm so pissed
great job drock i'm setting up an epic
moment there he is a little punch buggy
i'm proud of you i'm also proud of how
strong i am
it's nice how much for the cars um
would you do 20 for both
no i don't think so
did you want this yes but if you really
really want to you knocked yourself out
go ahead
okay you got it
go 15 in the middle all right you do 20
on this 35 for all of you
yeah
yeah awesome
i'll be right back
we did extremely well here
things are going to be very good now
the day is made
[Music]
how much for this bucket um six
maybe go seven if you throw that in uh
let's do eight
have a great day he wanted 30 he wanted
20. he wanted eight and he wanted three
for the minions one at 61 got 43 and got
destroyed
[Music]
what's that lady keep beating us she's
not beating us this time and she knows
it her goose is cooked
big shout out david
i know nothing about dvds
oh
why
that's why
he punched me earlier with a punch buggy
i'm so happy right now that is the
highlight of my trip right
how much were these two little things
dollar for both how's that sound sounds
more than fine
notice her strategy see what she did
smart she saw that i was here so she's
like let me go to that one because he
hasn't hit that one yet that's extremely
well played i'm like impressed by that
[Music]
[Music]
smells like horse
i gotta learn christmas i really do
this is so cool how much is this my
friend my father and i built that in
the 70s i wanted to get like a hundred
dollars for it let me give it some
thought thank you
i want to talk
look this is why i do trash talk i'm not
going to buy everything because i'm
going to buy the [ __ ] that i care about
but i promise you i would have destroyed
that man's face and got it for 50 i
would have then been able to easily put
that on facebook marketplace craigslist
instagram and probably get 300 to 500
bucks this is the thing that i keep
thinking about i don't have money you do
have the ability to google a town-wide
sale you have the ability to spend 20 on
gas and you have the ability to rip a
man's face off and i use that as like
slang for like negotiate well you saw i
want to maybe get 100. drock i was
taking that guy down at 50. i might just
buy it for 50 just to make my point
my friend would you take 50 for it
yeah all right [ __ ] told you
[Music]
oh this thing
i'm barely going and this thing will
whip i gotta be
careful this was worth it
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
just happened
i'm gonna ride on the highway
oh there's a cop
quick camera down
[Music]
i'm holy [ __ ] garyvee
how are you i'm doing well how are you
man good man you're garage sale hunting
all right very good can i just get your
license i just need to take it down
saying that i uh spoke to you and you'll
be good to go all right man what's your
name james pleasure pleasure hang tight
one sec okay
one three to one nine there's no problem
here that was [ __ ] amazing
someone just called they were concerned
i guess they thought
i was like i was like i saw you i knew
you guys were i was like man i was like
i was like did i miss a stop sign didn't
see oh the film and got it was a
pleasure such a pleasure man thank you
brother thank you have a great day thank
you take care guys thanks you know who i
think might have called the cops on us
the lady it was a sneaky move by her to
stop us i really respect her game garage
sale fugitives
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey guys to meet you thank you bro
what's your name tj steve steve
how much is this 40 40. i'm just so not
educated on these
probably just left some real money on a
table from pokemon
guys such a pleasure nice meeting you
got pulled over met some fans passing
some pokemon firsts it was an eventful
four minutes
[Music]
she paid a dollar for the toy story dude
let's see
you know what this is right yeah but it
doesn't hurt
how much 18.
wow
i don't even know if i want to slug it
by the way for anybody who's watching
the amount of lego things we're passing
on that are pure money-making is huge
thank you so much
take five take five i mean it's five
feels like i have to take it how much is
this little game i'm just doing a dollar
piece on that table you got it thank you
so much we took a risk drock i have no
idea didn't even look it up but it is my
favorite number take five gabrielle all
right
not bad for a dollar
prediction greatest garage sale
time
hi guys
how are you i would love some lemonade
thank you
you keep the change okay oh my gosh
thank you so much you're welcome
worth 20 bucks it's right about the
greatest garage sale ever got to pay 20
bucks to a young girl do you see her
face how awesome is that that was my
face in 1985 when that bike rider
dropped by and gave me a 10 bill i'll
never forget it literally for the rest
of my life
[Music]
you just seen your face when i just did
that trying to keep my calories down
[Music]
i mean this could i have a mug i'll just
dismantle
that there we go enjoy have a wonderful
day thank you easy good dive is a good
brand it's all brand drock one day
people will be buying beef friends mugs
and garage sales and the whole thing
will be full circle
[Music]
feeling good about this one drock
i'm feeling less good
i'm feeling atrocious now
have a great day
[Music]
i would have bet that we would have been
pulled over more than i would have been
petting a dog i'm not even kidding
bet you that's 50 cents you can get 15
for it it's mug life it's a 10 spot for
a quarter it's all day
i like the mug life
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
have a great day
how do you train a dragon
i paid one to train this dragon it's 13.
trash talk watch what i'm about to do
with eight quarters two bucks let's go
[Music]
it says two get one free on the mugs and
then these two little smirks so dollar
and then maybe a dollar for those two
okay see ya take care all right now the
fun part life is good mug
can't find it exactly but let's call
this an easy 10 spot based on what i'm
seeing next denny's you're not going to
believe this
11 14 bucks all day
this is just a vintage one but just for
fun holy [ __ ] 12 bucks for two of them
now smurf baseball 1981 so that's 10
50 for the catcher shipping what's that
you're gonna make 29
like i really believe that's you know
two to three hours at target i love this
[ __ ]
[Music]
i know i just see those what's that
i am
oh my god
i'm sorry
what are you sorry about
your biggest favorite that's awesome man
thank you i gotta call him call him call
him she watches you all the time thank
you bro what's your name my name is
dylan dylan dude this is great facetime
i'll say what's up what's up man what's
up fam
i really appreciate that my guy thank
you he's been running his own business
for a few years hello where are you
my [ __ ] guy that's right well it was
good to meet you bro keep pushing i want
to see it yeah show me my brother oh the
sneakers he runs his own i love it good
for him
good [ __ ] he started at stockx and then
him and his friend used the training to
start like their own thing good for them
they keep blowing up it's going well he
watched you all the time thank you man
man thank you brother i'm so flattered
by it before you leave what were you
actually looking for are you out looking
for a certain thing where basically i'm
trying to get people to understand that
like complain that they have no money
and they can't do anything that you
could go garage selling with twenty
dollars buy [ __ ] flip it buy [ __ ] flip
it
that's how i built my life really nice
meeting all of you take care of
yourselves bye-bye
that was nice
what a perfect way to end i'm trying to
do more for the soul way less for the
bridge
all right let's go through the
highlights of this episode first and
foremost number one highlight giving
that 20 build to that young lady that
matters to me always give back to the
game that started you off another
humongous highlight i mean the soapbox
car from the 60s just insane he wanted a
hundred he didn't get it that whole toy
collection that i picked up on that was
nuts what else was the highlight drock
[ __ ] to find two punch buggies in the
wild that is wild oh yeah pulled over
that was a highlight let's see the
draftkings odds on me getting pulled
over and now let's see even more
ridiculous odds let's see the odds of me
petting a dog you know i think back to
the reality of business even though i
didn't pick up stuff i was talking
through like this would have been ten
dollars for 60 bucks this would have
been 20 400 bucks i left hundreds of
items so different than episode six
where everything was ice cold another
fun thing to show every given saturday
is different final thoughts just like
with every episode there's gonna be
plenty of comments about gas fees and
ebay fees and just a culture of why not
versus why yes and uh if you're part of
this community please understand that
the answer is always yes get your ass
out next weekend take 100 bucks go with
a buddy a family member you'll remember
the stories there'll be fun days it's a
good time and you'll make three four
five six seven eight hundred bucks
why not wow
[Music]
come on
[Music]
hey everybody just want to talk through
these cars with all of y'all so we went
on ebay and found the average price per
car was around 2.48
so we multiplied that number by our
total number of cars which ended up
being 434 so that totaled to just above
a thousand dollars and then we added
that price to the profit from the
miscellaneous toys that gary also picked
up at that sale so that is the total
number that you're seeing here so all of
that being said if you were to do the
same thing but you sold all the cars in
bulk that price that you're seeing would
vary
[Music]
you